plusieurs millions de français se
croiser sur les routes de juillet et
d'août
l'ong week-end dangereux réaction au
plan de redressement de la sécurité
sociale les médecins et les hôpitaux
mais le mal est européen le cas allemand
car père aux américains et des mois
contre les grandes compagnies
pétrolières
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir au cours
des quelques jours qui viennent 10 entre
demain et vendredi prochain 3 ou presque
20 millions de français vont prendre la
soie pour rentrer de vacances parce que
ce n'est pas suite de vacances soit pour
aller reprendre ce qui fait un peu envie
à ceux qui ne partent pas encore à la
veille de ces grands départs la sécurité
routière lance un cri d'alarmé devant la
forte progression des accidents qu'on
enregistre depuis le début de 1979 par
rapport à l'an passé
pour les cinq premiers mois de cette
année près de 100 mille accidents ce qui
fait 8 sont parrainés qui a eu sur les
routes 90 morts et 850 blessés de plus
que l'an dernier à la même époque la
sécurité routière explique cette
augmentation des accidents par le non
respect de la limitation de vitesse
depuis le 1er juillet cent cinquante
deux opérations de contrôles ont été
effectués par la gendarmerie et la
police
monsieur quels ont été les résultats de
ces opérations de contrôle le plus le
1er juillet ses résultats ont été de 13
mille cinq cent soixante huit procès
verbaux pour excès de vitesse sont bien
déclaré monsieur boon emilie l'intérieur
c'est l'une des principales causes des
accidents graves de la circulation
les conseils sont donc évidemment à la
prudence prudence pour vous bien sûr
mais aussi prudence pour les autres pour
vous inciter à la sagesse de nombreux
contrôles seront effectués ces prochains
jours concernant les retours de vacances
notre bison futé nationale vous
recommande d'éviter de circuler les
vendredis 27 juillet et samedi 28
quant aux horaires conseillers pour
l'aider par ces trois prochains jours
les voici
vendredi des embouteillages sont
annoncés entre 15h et 21h en direction
de la province
samedi 28 juillet il serait bon de ne
pas prendre la route entre 3h du matin
et 15 heures
il est préférable de partir l'après midi
enfin et c'est le dernier conseil de
bison futé pour cette fin de semaine il
sera difficile de circuler dimanche
matin jusqu'à midi
prudence évidemment l'un des premières
français n'est plus vrai tout le monde
le connaît bien
mais tout le monde ne me respecte pas on
ne peut pas le respecter prudence est
mère de sûreté
je vous souhaite à tous les cas bien vu
maints d'arriver à bon port parmi les
régions où l'on compte déjà une très
forte densité de vacanciers il y à la
côte d'azur mais tout le monde mais huit
pages en hôtel et vous êtes nombreux
qu'ils devaient aller au marché
régulièrement pour acheter votre
alimentation
alors à quel prix peut-on y remplir le
panier de la ménagère
selon que l'on fait ses emplettes sur la
côte ou bien à l'intérieur des terres où
est si un reportage de jean marie douce
première constatation pendant le
week-end dernier pas d'énormes
différences de prix entre les marchés de
draguignan à l'intérieur des terres et
celui de sainte maxime sur la côte du
moins pour trois produits les tomates
les pêches et les melons ainsi pour un
kilo de tomates par exemple font le
trouve de 2 francs à cinq francs à
draguignan dimanche de 3,6 à
sainte-maxime pas d'écart à justifier
non plus pour les pêches et les melons
deuxième constatation la vente directe
au bord des routes le producteur vend
aux consommateurs sans intermédiaire
elle est réellement meilleur marché le
même kilo de tomates de 1 franc 50 à 250
le melon de 3 à 4 francs le kilo les
pêches ne sont pas toujours moins cher
mais dans l'ensemble des achats
avantageux à condition de faire l'effort
de ne pas tout acheter au coin de la rue
en arrivant on a l'impression qu'on va
dépenser davantage parce qu'on n'est pas
habitué du commerce intérieur
mais en cherchant bien on trouve des
commerces là cherchent à contrôler
commercre shekels on peut s'alimenter au
25e chez soi tout en restant moins cher
que l'épicerie de la plage certains
supermarchés sont plus sensibles à des
hausses de prix estivale dans le var les
relevés de prix de l'union fédérale des
consommateurs indique une hausse de 4 à
8% entre mai et juillet sur un ensemble
de 100 produite est ce qu de grande
consommation des tarifs pour touristes
jugent cette ménagère varoise
le soleil n'a pas endormi sa vigilance
ça commence aux environs pas qu'à peu
près la vie commence à augmenter tout
doucement pas vous dire exactement ce
chiffre c'est évident pour viandes et
poissons il est difficile d'établir une
moyenne dont l'éventail des prix est
large et beaucoup de vacanciers se
rabattre sur les salades fait les
traiteurs elles ne sont pas toujours
très bon marché comme cette salade
exotique
selon le test de l'union des
consommateurs du var elle revient à 15
francs 9 de marchandises 6 de salaire
vous allez plutôt au restaurant vous
nous servez chez le traiteur vous
préparer les choses vont mal
plus tôt à la maison parce qu'on est
d'abord une famille avec trois enfants
rarement celle 7 heures parce que les
prix sont très chers faisait lever et
plus de temps en temps au restaurant
mais la loi du moindre effort
le manque d'enthousiasmé pour les
encombrements sur la route du
supermarché ou tout simplement le
dépaysement ne poussent guère les
vacanciers consommateurs à la vigilance
l'augmentation des prix que nous
constatons dans nos relevés est due à
une diminution de la vigilance des
consommateurs leur conseillons donc de
continuer à surveiller les prix et a
accepté de faire quelques centaines de
mètres de plus pour trouver les magasins
moins cher en ce qui concerne les
services en particulier les restaurants
nous avons constaté certains abus criard
bien qu'autorisée là aussi le
consommateur doit savoir refuser un plat
comme par exemple que nous ont pu
remarquer le chapon à 240 francs pour
deux personnes à sainte maxime
alors si vous voulez éviter le temps
banier à tous les repas à la fin de vos
vacances
soyez attentifs compris dès votre
arrivée
hier soir ici même monsieur jacques
barrot ministre de la santé de la
sécurité sociale est venu vous expliquer
le plan adopté en conseil des ministres
le matin pour redresser la situation
financière de sécurité sociale il
s'agite au premier chef d'enrayer une
situation particulièrement préoccupante
l'accroissement des dépenses de santé de
22 % par an ce qui pouvait déboucher à
la fin de l'année prochaine si on ne
prenait pas de mesures à un déficit
cumulé de 24 milliards de francs actuels
naturellement le plan mise au point qui
comprend entre autres un effort
temporaire de 18 mois demandés aux
assurés sociaux visent en priorité
disait ge à freiner l'augmentation des
dépenses de santé
ce plan repose sur quatre mesures
essentielles que rappelle jacques
mirville way quatre mesures essentielles
dont la première concerne l'ensemble des
salariés et quelques assurés sociaux
notamment les agriculteurs à partir du
1er août vous savez nous paierons 1% au
titre d'ascot sociale en plus sur
l'ensemble de notre salaire c'est une
mesure qui est extrêmement simple si
vous gagnez 3000 francs par mois et bien
vous paierez chaque mois 30 francs en
plus pour la scop sociale ce qui mesure
à caractère exceptionnel et limité dans
le temps
elle ne devrait pas durer plus de 18
mois la seconde mesure concerne les
médecins et les dentistes les tarif de
leur consultation ne seront pas relevés
en octobre et en janvier prochain comme
c'était prévu troisième mesure une
contribution de l'état qui prendra à sa
charge la formation des étudiants en
médecine cela va lui coûter de 3 à 4
milliards de francs
et puis l'état prêtera également 5
milliards de francs inscrits et social
enfin un quatrième mesure les budgets
des hôpitaux publics seront bloqués par
exemple ici à la pitié salpêtrière
le budget voté pour cette année est de
680 millions de francs eh bien le
directeur de cet hôpital ne devra pas
dépasser ce budget si en fin d'année il
voit que ce n'est pas en se levant tôt
rue à un rythme un peu trop rapide
il devra prendre des mesures d'économies
alors monsieur raynaud vous êtes
présidente de la fédération hospitalière
qu'est ce qui pourrait être fait à titre
d'exemple pour précisément réaliser ces
économies mais il faut d'abord resituer
le contexte de ses économies dans le
cadre du service public hospitalier
si les dépenses augmentent trop vite
c'est qu'il y aura des malades
supplémentaires qui auront besoin de
soins et qui se présenteront à nous pour
les soigner à la foire correctement et
en maintenant la qualité
si nous n'avons pas une enveloppe
extensive
nous devrons donc faire des économies
par arielle kaeslin par exemple par
exemple il n'est pas question de ne pas
payer le personnel qui aura des
améliorations de situation financière en
fonction d'érosion monétaire mais nous
serons tentés naturellement de nous
rabattre sur les dépenses d'entretien
seront vraisemblablement les premières
victimes de ce blocage entretien des
bâtiments pour des marchés qui ne
seraient pas encore passé diminution ou
ralentissement des achats de matériel et
de produits d'entretien
alors ne vous avons déjà donné a
simplement ou de réaction voici celle de
la confédération syndicale des médecins
français qui l'ont d'ailleurs déjà donné
ici c'est tout le système de santé de
notre société qui est remise en cause
coop à la fédération des syndicats
pharmaceutiques c'est à dire les
pharmaciens d'officine comme l'on dit
elle indique qu'en raison de la
fragilité de leur équilibre économique
les pharmaciens ne sont pas en état de
supporter une contribution de 1,5 pour
cent sur le revenu de 1979 un ennemi
pour cent donc même à titre exceptionnel
pendant toute cette semaine nous vous
avons présenté des enquêtes reportages
sur la santé et nous continuons avec le
souci de vous permettre de faire des
comparaisons sur la situation chez nous
et chez les autres 20 10 nous avions
commencé par l'italie mardi c'est de la
france hier avec monsieur ben arous et
un autre spécial santé demain ce sera la
grande bretagne
je vous invite à suivre ce soir le
reportage de michel meyer représentant
permanente
antenne 2 1 république fédérale
d'allemagne relation de cause à effet la
santé est devenue une vedette de la
télévision depuis deux ans les émissions
sur la prévention des maladies communes
vienne où le bon usage du sauna ou 10
sport se sont multipliées sur le sud de
l'allemagne
c'est une médecin speakerine tu
consultes parce qu'ils écran interposé
elle est elle même très surprise de son
succès van basten est bon dans
l'audience est inespéré il dit elle elle
va même au delà des frontières de la
république fédérale ce qui suggère bien
entendu à notre docteur ès télévisée la
mise en place d'une europe de la santé
par les ondes avec échanges de
programmes et de spécial et moi aussi je
serais très heureuse d'avoir la chance
de dire un jour où tous les
téléspectateurs français donne santé
dans la presse même intérêt plus
critiqué plus irrespectueux pour les
travaux de médecins dont on attend un
peu moins de miracle que dans le passé
on s'aperçoit en effet que les hommes en
blanc sont des citoyens normaux et
qu'ils en ont les mêmes faiblesses et
appétit renfort inattendu pour une
presse allemand de très sensible aux
angoisses de son public une sommité de
l'orthopédie le professeur yu sacré
talent
depuis un an il a déclaré une guerre
totale à ses confrères
ces livres sont devenus des best-sellers
est ce que si tu souhaites tu as
annemassienne telle opération un
troisième en aux chirurgiens
entreprennent sur leurs patients des
opérations nous n'accepterons ni pour
eux ni pour leurs amis et spatiaux tsoup
of time héros souvent les médecins
prescrivent des médicaments qu'ils ne
prendraient pas eux mêmes souvent aussi
des opérations sont réalisées par des
débutants
incapable de les accomplir
cette médecine allemand de coûte très
cher aux caisses publiques qui dépensent
actuellement 80 milliards de
deutschemarks par an soit deux fois plus
qu'en 74,6 l'explosion des coûts se
poursuit au rythme actuel les
cotisations augmenteront au point qu'en
l'an 2000 elles mangeront l'intégralité
du salaire de la sueur et social ce
serait la mort d'un système d'assurance
assez exemplaire
créé par bismarck à la fin du siècle
dernier de la même manière que je suis
de médecins et en pharmacie
il me suffit de présenter ces
ordonnances pour recevoir gratuitement
tous les médicaments prescrits par
non-médecins gratuitement c'est beaucoup
dire car il me faudra tout de même payer
un marc je dirais symbolique par
médicaments prescrits
peut-être pour que je n'oublie pas que
ces médicaments coûtent cher et qui sont
payés réellement par ma caisse
d'assurance maladie
c'est là en quelque sorte une forme
d'éducation en effet la gratuité des
médicaments gratuité apparente n'est pas
en allemagne fédérale
un facteur qui réduit leur consommation
tout au contraire la surconsommation de
médicaments est en effet devenu un
problème de société en allemagne on en
consomme un peu à tout propos et en
toutes circonstances dans un pays où les
produits pharmaceutiques sont en moyenne
plus cher que partout ailleurs en europe
c'est là aussi un facteur qui favorise
l'explosion du coût de la santé le lobby
allemand de l'industrie chimique profite
bien naturellement de cette situation
avec 12 milliards de deutschemarks par
an c'est l'équivalent du budget d'un
état comme la finlande qui est engloutie
dans la consommation de médicaments
freiner cette dépense est donc l'un des
objectifs prioritaires des autorités de
bonnes
nous pensons rien de bon d'une
nationalisation de la santé j'aurai
encore plus de bureaucratie serait à
craindre
cela correspondrait à encore moins
déficiences et surtout pas à une
amélioration des prestations services
nous avons par exemple dit il au cours
des dernières années
fixer un plafond pour les gains des
médecins et les dépenses pour les
médicaments ça aura à vrai dire le débat
allemand sur la politique de santé n'est
pas d'ordre idéologique dans un pays où
l'on va de plus en plus sur le médecin
comme chez un mécanicien du corps humain
le financement de la santé soulève
certes des problèmes aigus mais ils sont
mineurs par rapport à ce que pose la
déshumanisation la robotisation de la
médecine si vous voyez les les hôpitaux
chez nous en acier envers son but est
vrai cauchemar et débreaks casemate de
médical ou entre est oui où on traite t
machine ce sont des des fabriques mehdi
médicaux mais ce sont plus des des lieux
où il ya des des relations normales
c'est vrai que dans certaines cliniques
on se croirait dans un laboratoire de la
nasa
il reste qu'en matière de diagnostic
complexe les travaux remarquables des
médecins allemands sont reconnus et
respectés dans le monde entier conflit
aigu entre le président carter et des
grandes firmes pétrolières américaines
de quoi s'agit-il et bien ces compagnies
vont s'aligner progressivement les prix
du pétrole produit aux états unis même
sur les prix du pétrole du marché
mondial ce faisant elles réaliseront des
super bénéfices
le sénat est saisi d'un projet d'impôt
sur ces supers profits et selon le
président carter le lobby du pétrole
multiplie ses efforts pour que cet impôt
ne serait pas mort
les compagnies pétrolières américaines
on les appelle les majors parce que ce
sont les plus puissantes du monde et si
elles sont si puissantes financièrement
même politiquement si parce que leurs
profits qui était déjà énorme à
l'échelle multinationales se sont mis
depuis la crise pétrolière a augmenté
formidablement quelques exemples en
trois mois les profits de exxon
c'est-à-dire et sow ont pris 23% mobile
30 % celle 50% standard oil 70% et c'est
pourquoi en schématisant quand vous
prenez temps pour cent sur un produit
donné plus le produit augmente à la base
et plus vous gagnerez d'argent c'est
évident et ce produit de base pour les
pétroliers c'est bien sûr le pétrole
brut du proche orient et d'ailleurs et
il augmente sans arrêt et puis les
majors américaines exploite aussi le
pétrole national celui du sol américain
et par décision de l'exécutif de jimmy
carter ces prix là vont monter aussi
nouveau super profits enfin les
compagnies pétrolières sont
gestionnaires des stocks au fur et à
mesure des hausses du brut
en retenant un maximum de pétrole dans
les cuves avant chaque os pour l'écouler
après on peut gagner énormément d'argent
cela bien sûr peut parfois perturber la
distribution
les américains qui ont fait la queue
devant leurs pompes à essence en savent
quelque chose
et c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
les majeures sont si impopulaire
et c'est en s'appuyant d'ailleurs sur
cette impopularité que jimmy carter
s'attaque aux pétroliers que leur dit-il
il dit rendez l'argent
remettez tous ces supers profits dans
mon plan énergétique
en effet énergies nouvelles carburant
synthétique tout cela nous en avons
parlé va coûter des milliards de dollars
l'état ne peut pas tout payer lui-même
si les compagnies pétrolières ni
investissent à il n'y a plus de plan
carter alors la consommation continuera
de s'envoler avec de graves conséquences
sur les prix sur le dollar et sur toute
l'économie mondiale l'enjeu est donc
énorme
or les majeurs ne sont pas du tout
disposés à payer il préférerait
conserver leurs investissements pour la
recherche pétrolière classique qui coûte
de plus en plus cher et comme leur
énorme puissance financière leur donne
aussi de très nombreux appuis politiques
au congrès c'est une bataille qui est
loin d'être gagné d'avancé pour jimmy
carter selon notre ministère du budget
et les recettes fiscales de l'étang
progressé en france de presque 16 % au
premier semestre par rapport à la même
période de l'an dernier
c'est la taxe intérieure sur les
produits pétroliers qui est l'impôt
ayant le plus progressé
57 % d'une année sur l'autre le conseil
constitutionnel qui avait été saisi par
les députés et les sénateurs de
l'opposition a rendu sa décision et a
confirmé que la loi organisant
l'exercice du droit de grève à la radio
et à la télévision était conforme à la
constitution
le conseil a seulement modifier
légèrement les dispositions relatives au
programme minimum en cas de grève
la loi va donc être promu lié avec les
modifications apportées par le conseil
constitutionnel
aujourd'hui commence le ramadan ce mois
qui est au coeur de l'année pour tous
les musulmans c'est pendant 28 jours une
période de méditation de réflexion et de
prière mais aussi une épreuve physique
car le ramadan signifie le jeûne entre
le lever et le coucher du soleil
et ce jeune a une influence directe sur
le travail
il faut que nos compatriotes musulmans
qui suivent ce mois dans la joie et la
ferveur puisse avoir le sentiment de la
solidarité un tiers de toute la
population
quelle que soit la confession de chacun
c'est ce qu'a rappelé aujourd'hui
monsieur jacques dominati secrétaires
d'état auprès du premier
monsieur kaddoumi chef du département
politique de l'olp et a quitté paris
aujourd'hui après une visite de travail
de deux jours
il avait eu un entretien d'une heure et
demi à peu près avec monsieur jean
françois-poncet notamment à propos de la
situation sur le terrain au liban le
ministre français des affaires
étrangères avait exprimé ses
préoccupations au sujet de cette
situation et il a rappelé que la france
venait de faire part de ce sentiment au
gouvernement israélien
après les récents bombardements du liban
par l'aviation israël l'éventualité
d'une visite en france de mesures sera
pas tu n'as pas été évoquée mais bien
entendu on a parlé de l'attentât
d'avant-hier contre le chef du
département militaire de la lp mais
césaire moselle a battu avant-hier à
minuit devant son domicile à cannes et
qui après un coma d'une quarantaine
d'heures est décédé cet après midi à
l'hôpital saint roch de nice mais ce
monsieur n'a été tué par un inconnu qui
n'a fait qu'une seule fois atteignant sa
victime au front yasser arafat crois que
les auteurs de l'attentât seraient des
agents israéliens
mais ce n'est pas du tout l'opinion de
police française on rechercherait plutôt
du côté de certains groupes pro
israélien aux irakiens excusez moi ou
égyptiens mais dans ce domaine il faut
bien se garder de conclure hâtivement et
l'anc est naturellement continue les
richesses c'est bien j'ai une dépêche de
l'afp
qui dit que l'atmosphère n'est pas à la
détente pour les correspondants
étrangers à moscou où l' agence
france-presse
est venue s'ajouter à la liste des
organes d'information dont les
représentants ont des bisbilles avec les
autorités soviétiques
le directeur du bureau de moscou afp 17
dps de l'alliance a été convoqué au
ministère des affaires étrangères qui a
attiré son attention sur la conduite
indigne
andré guimet de 3d correspond à voir du
bureau et qui encore une fois en
primaire enfreignent systématiquement
les lois soviétique et un avertissement
similaire a été formulée à l'encontre du
'financial times' il ya des régions dans
le monde
oui est facile de faire son métier il y
en a d'autres où ça est un peu moins
précis une spectaculaire évasion vers
lundi au palais de justice de bruxelles
celle de françois bès celui là même qui
est déjà s'était évadé en 78 de la
prison de la santé à paris en compagnie
de jacques mesrine et dont l'odyssée à
l'époque avait longuement défrayé la
chronique comme on vit baisse était
emprisonné
depuis quelques mois en belgique et il
allait être prochainement extradé vers
la france
mais cet homme plusieurs fois condamné
pour vol à main armée est la véritable
spécialiste de l'évasion et ce matin à
bruxelles il a échappé à la police pour
la cinquième fois
oui en effet françois bès comparaissait
ce matin devant le juge d'instruction à
bruxelles pour des délits mineurs tels
port d'armes et usage de faux papiers
désirant ainsi comme venait de le faire
remarquer bien retarder son extradition
vers la france
alors à peine assis sur le banc en face
du juge d'instruction françoise se
glisse une main soulevant la son cachet
plusieurs revolver qui était collée au
bois avec l'un d'eux ils menacent le
juge sort rapidement du palais de
justice prenant donc le juger en otage
la l'attend un complice sur une moto il
s'évade l'évasion réussie françois bès
laisse le juge sur le trottoir pour vous
rappeler un peu la personnalité de
françois je dirais qu'il a 35 ans que
c'est un homme qui était condamné
plusieurs fois pour des vols à main
armée pour des hold-up était condamné
notamment une fois par les assises de la
gironde à 15 ans de réclusion criminelle
mais c'est un spécialiste de l'évasion
il s'est évadé deux fois de la prison de
gradignan une fois de la prison de
fresnes
et puis vous l'avez rappelé avec jacques
mesrine s'était lui-même 1978 de la
prise en main forte pour le moment ils
courent toujours
il portera un tiercé se disent plus est
aujourd'hui à evry arrivée tumultueuse
enquête des commissaires résultats 1er
le nup sliimy deuxième le 6 marion
troisième le cette gare ont donc 9 6 7
les rapports sont les suivants 1891 dans
l'ordre et 275 56 ordre ceci pour 5
francs sport tennis coupe de galéa la
finale serait la même que l'année
dernière c'est à dire tu es le sauve
acquis contre france les nôtres en effet
ont battu les italiens yannick noah en
battant marco alciati pardon 6-3 6-3 a
qualifié l'équipe française la finale se
joue demain vendredi samedi et dimanche
l'an passé la france avait gagnés contre
les tchèques slovaques caprins ce sera
sans doute plus difficile cette année
tour de france à la voile roscoff brest
arrivé 1er dunkerque 2e marseille 3e can
classement général 1er brest 2e
marseille voici le reportage dans
régaler l'homme d'antenne 2 dans ce tour
de france à la voile
alapage saint malo sur le carnet de bord
du bateau d'antenne 2 mais rebelle vent
nul et un spectacle assez inhabituel 25
voiliers sur la ligne de départ obligé
de mouiller leur encre si le vent
n'était pas à l'appel le courant
contraire lui était la faisant reculer
les bateaux comme disent les marins
trois heures après le signal de départ
quelques voiliers avait tout de même
réussi à progresser d'une centaine de
mètres une moyenne insuffisante
toutefois et le jury prenait la décision
de faire remorquer les bateaux pour
donner un nouveau départ au large à la
queue leu leu derrière le trois mâts du
père jaouen et de nuit les first 30 du
tour de france à la voile sans aller
vers la haute mer à la recherche du vent
perdu au petit matin la brise était au
rendez vous et les 25 voiliers
reprenaient leur régate en direction de
roscoff sur le bateau d'antenne 2 un
skipper de première force ce gène
riguidel là parce que c'est des bateaux
qui pour en temps réel et avec des
équipages compétents alors c'est une
belle bagarre oui pourriez prendre un
bateau ils ont tout le monde oui j'ai
déjà fait l'année dernière d'ailleurs
mais manque de chance on avait gagné la
manche a été annulée alors là comme ça
cette année
sabato d'accompagnement il ya moins de
risques est ce que ce type de course
vous paraît difficile je pense que le
parcours est très sélectif parce que
c'est un parcours le long du littoral et
avec tout par exemple la bretagne
actuellement il ya quand même beaucoup
de coincer décide à négocier les
courants également donc c'est sûrement
difficile mais roscoff vue de terre
c'est un endroit charmant sur l'eau
c'est un peu le revers de la médaille la
proche du port demande beaucoup
d'attention les cailloux à fleurs un peu
partout et comme dit le dicton si le
navire n'obéit pas au gouvernail au
rocher il obéit toujours
l'équipage du touquet l'apprendra à ses
dépens l'acquis de leur voilier sans
doute en manque d'affection s'en allant
caresser les écailles rosconi on
entendra même une de ces demoiselles
hurler à la radio je veux rentrer à la
maison
plaisir de vous y retrouver
bon courage bon vent échouage marée
basse pour les 25 voiliers aligné dans
le vieux port de roscoff une occasion à
ne pas perdre pour effectuer un brin de
toilette sur les coques après la mer du
nord et la manche les voiliers du tour
de france entame aujourd'hui la partie
atlantique de leur périple sur les côtes
françaises
premier au classement général l'équipage
de brest précède marseille de 40 minutes
pour l'instant les bretons restent
favoris car les prochaines étapes de la
course se déroule sur leur terrain dans
quelques minutes à 20h30 c'est le début
de la saison de football 79 80 elle
durera dix mois elle s'achèvera fin mai
une saison qui a déjà été marqué avant
même le coup d'envoi par plusieurs
transferts de champion voici sur l'écran
les panneaux des rencontres de la soirée
avec ce que je considère d'abord comme
le match du jour
compte tenu des résultats de l'an passé
bordeaux strasbourg et puis tous les
matchs s'inscrivent sur votre écran
je vous laisse regarder ramasse temps le
temps de main sur la moitié nord de la
france après dissipation des brumes
matinales temps se payer malgré des
nuages abondant près des côtes de la
manche
quelques pluies éparses pourront se
produire et même des orages isolés des
températures minimales sont en hausse et
sur la moitié sud
après une matinée brumeuse le temps sera
ensoleillé malgré quelques foyers
orageux isolés qui affecteront sur tout
le massif central les alpes et la corse
les températures
resteront élevés le dernier journal vous
sera présentée tout à l'heure par
bernard pradines haut n'oubliez pas
demain antenne de midi présenté par
daniel bilalian
et si vous le voulez bien me
retrouveront demain soir à 20 heures
bonsoir